you
hi everyone is jerry amount Ches calm
and I just got paired up playing a
five-o game so let's see what we get an
e4 e5 game okay let's go with a scotch
opening probably play more royal apes'
than anything but let's give this a
whirl
Queen h4 Bishop c5 okay let's go with
the capture expecting Queen b6 now whoo
well Queen f6 was a move and probably
more common than this so they just
damaged their clean side structure so
what do I want
I want a King and pawn endgame and then
I could put this four versus three
healthy four versus three majority in
motion so where to deploy my pieces it's
a pretty early quick pretty early Queen
exchange let's see I think this is a
good start because it also interferes
with a good post for the light square
bishop and do I want to castle
I don't think I do I'm going to step up
I'm assuming they're they're preparing
Bishop there and I'll actually have a
decision to take or just back up so this
was my idea
this structure controls the night I'm
also preparing Bishop here I could start
with rook to d1 or Bishop here here's
another thing maybe I would like to do
this and put my knight on b3 yeah let's
for this I'll just immediately exchange
and I want to see where this bishops
going to go so they're considering
taking with the pond yeah interesting
all right let's ask the bishop a
question you fish it back a four a five
a four either grab some more space or
they stop me and place a pond on a dark
square and I could potentially target it
if the pond is on 85 I might reposition
my Knight to c4 I have to be down the
lookout for this maneuver into f4 okay
they made a move I didn't see it well
here's another thing I could go with
this and have this pawn lock down in the
structure and now trade dark square
bishop and a knight on this square it's
not quite a hole but in a way because I
have a pot on a5 it is it'll be
difficult to kick a night off off of the
c5 square for as long as I keep my brook
on the a file so they're combating this
idea of 95 I think now is a good time to
change the structure and I'm doing this
to just stop the knight from posting up
on e5 and I should probably keep my pawn
on f4 and we're going to recapture so I
have a two versus one now and maybe I
give up on the a file hmm let's go with
this truck here still keep my a rock
around in case I do get here and you
know maybe if the a file opens up with
b6 so let's see how do they continue to
improve lets rule out Knight to g4 and
this advanced I believe I'll post up on
g5 they might try for something like
this creating a passed pawn so so far
it's just been a lot of restriction just
preventing what it is my opponent wants
to do many trades of course got a
30-second advantage on the clock so
they're struggling to come up with
something I wouldn't mind having my
knight on d3 instead of b3 we observed
still c5 and has an idea of jumping into
e5 at some point
so I think now I jump in here and how
how annoying would this be here and then
rook to b3 so if I go here take stakes I
get a passed pawn but I also give up
this square maybe maybe I jump into c5
right now yeah let's jump into c5 right
now don't know if I'm threatening to
take they will get my be pawn in return
okay so I could take on d6 I could win I
could win material now so I could first
take on this square and then take here
I'm going to do not hang on if I take
here the ripple recapture and then the
rook is going to get here so I'm going
to take here first and I imagine they're
going to have to take here so now they
just recapture hmm I guess I can't take
on a six now they're just going to
exchange here okay well let's drop the
knight back they've straighten out their
structure they gain a little bit of
something there I believe
so I'm looking now to Knight positions I
don't know whose night stands better I'd
like to jump into e5 I have the better
King position that's that's something I
can say and let's post up here now that
I have control over a five or maybe okay
with capturing like this eh pond might
fall something like this might be right
around the corner I'm trying to fight
for control over a file to play a little
bit faster that I need far efore hits
with the tempo on c6 and let's get here
straight away I'm necessarily trying to
push but I may want to go pawn hunting
offsetting Knights I have a third ring
think they have a second rank Knight
let's step up here for starters and
[Music]
any tricks let me step over here yeah I
want to kind of box out the rook if I do
go in for this exchange I want my king
controlling squares on the G file that
move takes takes I have a check they
have everything can under control though
oh here's maybe another plan how about
rook here and I go on the other side of
the board if this I'll play this even
though my knight is a bit insecure
I just want to lock down on the
structure some he's unprotected now
interesting battle I do not like my time
situation this was my other idea trying
hunter this punt this pawn down although
they have that check let's return I miss
that idea yeah there take take advantage
the pin and strike 84 okay
Knight specific endgame here I take rook
takes pawn and I return to this square
and force of rook exchange so this is
back to a not-so-healthy structure very
certainly a position where you really
have to calculate well to defend my
knight get to take here and beyond this
night they're going to return put
pressure on my Jeep on maybe think about
pushing him but he has that hmm let's
just make a bit of a waiting move stop
a4 there's a fight going on over the f4
square evening out on the clock let's
get over there isn't a check now I can
force it
exchange still okay even now with this
and I'm going to take with the King I
believe yeah because I want to keep an
outside pass pawn let's step up one got
to come back to defend here should be
better for me let's come over here I
don't think they could get these
advances in let's step up hmm that isn't
really working well let's give this
check yeah and let's go here how to make
progress I was willing to give up this
pawn in order to go this direction to my
I am NOT going to be in time oh no I'm
not in time yeah this is way too slow
they could keep pushing okay now I don't
want to go there I'll try for this and
maybe I could somehow save this oh it's
still kind of tricky for black I believe
this Knight is a very good defender yes
he is a tricky guy are they going to
move wow what a game oh I wonder if I'm
with actually winning this because one
thing I can say is that there there is
an eventual Knight check that will
facilitate this final advance and there
isn't any good check for black in this
position I totally forgot about this
idea where why could push through to
create a passed pawn
giving up some material in order to do
so on the queenside is very well timed
yeah my King was just a little too far
away I don't think I was able to track
that guy down I pushed yeah so if I just
try to run in for it now
yeah I should have been aware of this my
king being in the so far away takes
takes here here you know I'm just not in
time just not working out for me uh yeah
let me let me bring up the analysis for
it and we'll just dive right in here and
see what more we can take away from this
interesting endgame okay here we go
before I look at the beginning I just
want to see what this ending is saying
okay this is winning for black width
I played b6 and kingi seven King e7 and
then I probably would have just pushed
Queen d6 so definitely not winning Queen
here is the save but I believe if black
doesn't go in for a king e7 if they just
bring the Queen back it might be a draw
or a win for me yeah there you go
setting a draw with b7 yeah it's it's
definitely really close they have to go
in for a check and well right around
this point can't I at least promote and
get a queen so apparently this is going
to be a draw but it's black ooh who has
to be more accurate they have to find
the point where it is a draw and then
you know win that type of ending that I
just showed
where I have a queen and upon plus
should have never got to that point but
okay there's just I want want to touch
on that ending it's too curious to see
if I just want to know if it was winning
or draw really close there so yeah
typically after this capture I'm used to
seeing clean f6 just ignoring the
capture and not going on castles
basically only here first throw a punch
at f2 and after let's say Queen f3 you
go in for the capture on c6 d take c6
and at least you're not uncatted but
yeah this is pretty unusual to me as
mentioned I'm only thinking about now
trading some pieces and one day trying
to play against this majority I have a
healthy kingside majority they have an
unhealthy Queen side majority so Bishop
c4 came there I don't know if there's
going to be too much in the middle game
to really cover I don't think they'll be
many shifts Knight f6 and f3 is pretty
standard 2 pawns control the night okay
I went in for this idea night into b3
and yeah I kind of gave up on this idea
to back up and keep the tension between
the bishops hoping one day for maybe a
capture and then I would have some play
on the a file I was leaning more towards
what happened in the game where I kind
of grabbed some Queen side space push my
a pawn down so Knight to b3 Knight c4
and what does it want to go with the
Bishop Bishop to b6 I think a4 is pretty
thematic a 4 and a 6
the other option you placed upon a dark
square he's potentially vulnerable it
may be the case that I gain control over
and hope and file because this would now
require the support of a rook and Bishop
to defend whereas I could allocate two
minor pieces to the defence of a five so
in a way it's like six points or putting
pressure on something that requires 13
points of defense so that mean somewhere
else on the board I'm likely favorable
so a six keeping the pawn off of a dark
square any five I'm putting my pawn on a
dark square he's potentially a target to
the bishop but not so much I mean
because I have this as an idea to trade
the dark square Bishop soph at this
point and tried to play against the
structure but they I mean they pushed
through I shouldn't have allowed that b6
move to happen so easily so I wonder if
I could have made a an adjustment when
things now shifted towards the Kings
side some so what did I do here I
controlled a five it wants to go with
Knight c1 oh that's interesting so
keeping the structure as is and maybe
repositioning the knight to d3 much
better square than b3 and I don't allow
any opening up of mountain Kings side so
quickly okay so that's an interesting
point so still keep the structure as is
go for a little maneuver things have
calmed down some I can watch over c4 as
well as soon as my knight is moved if
Knight to e5 I do have b3 if this is a
concern and it actually wouldn't even be
my knight on d3 controls b2 so i can
allow Knight to c4 and kind of sit this
is a really really good night and
defends defends be two stops entry
points along the D file if that was ever
an issue black doubling up and maybe I
could even look to clamp down on the
King King side structure some with my H
pawn so slow battle but uh
I'm the better side here from a
structural standpoint that's the that's
the key difference and maybe a direct
result of having the better structure is
that I could find a better post for my
king I think having the favorable
structure here implies that I'll acquire
a better King position give him a boot
step-up I know it's a third rank King
versus only a second rank King but that
still counts for something
these are just this is a position type
where it's a game of inches and they
they add up so I went right in for a 5
and then g5 it does like and things are
now opening up here and the King side I
wanted to keep control over this so g3
is there takes and I recapture g8 you
know I mean it's not even it's just
hovering around a half pawn advantage or
h2 g1 and what I want to do king f7
Knight to f6 h 3 now nice to see 5 ok so
I guess I'm winning out on some pawn
hunting variation Knight c5 Knight g4 my
King moves they take the H pawn I take
the D pawn I wanted to go with a more
controlled line and something to work
out more of yeah if you have some more
time but I was more of a keep things in
control guard is square don't even allow
Knight to g4 this is fine as well it's
not a critical type of position where I
have to go in for night to c5 I have I
have choices so this is why I played I
did go in for a night to c5 here it does
like that move and now b6 are right
around here well could I have done
different ah
you dummy I don't
have to take I miscalculated right on
this point because I thought I was going
to be winning upon with this and then I
take da pond but they're getting this
guy and this one's pretty far advanced
he's immediately passed in material wild
material would be even black all of a
sudden becomes better because they have
a passed pawn and that's a super
valuable passed pawn especially in
Knight end games having a pass trip on
the Knights hate having to defend a
pastor rook pawn so I just miscalculated
here with thinking I was going to win a
pawn forgetting that in the end there's
a root 2 G 3 moved from pulling the rook
off of the a file so I should not
capture I should keep this tension and
play Knight to d3 and this is still an
unhealthy structure and one where with a
little bit more preparation at some
point maybe I do take and then capture
and there really wouldn't be any fear of
this this is just way too weakening so
yeah I should have just dropped back to
d3 that's an improvement for me instead
of capturing on b6 still likes white
here about 93 immediately is better play
tonight to d3 here yeah so it still
likes white pink position my position is
good so where did it shift does it like
Richard g5 doesn't like rip to g5 I
should have jumped into e5 right now
improve my knight and now it's tricky it
still likes me
yeah but still keeping the structure as
is improve the night and throw a punch
at c6 c 5
what does it like after here rook to g5
only now
ah let's see rook g5 takes takes if the
knight goes to d7
I think it did pop out like that for a
second
this is I think I just know how to win
this
my king sneaks over here yeah this is
much more clear to me this rook and pawn
endgame better King position and I
already have a passed pawn
okay so Knight to e5 was another
improvement here instead of ripped to g5
straight away okay so they took I
recaptured and we're basically almost at
the end here KYNA for now I played to g1
maybe that got me into some trouble
they've actually go straight in for this
even with the night still on the board
but yeah it is tricky as we saw g4 and
do I have anything here night to be four
I was not even I was not even on the
radar going pawn hunting okay can you
have three a little bit of floundering
right around this point
c5 I'm just backing up I'm trying to get
this in but I don't know if I could
really do that maybe the computer will
say it's okay I'm at c4 and they improve
the King King g4 Knight to f6 is that a
good move yet so it's a good move and if
I take here oh they don't even have to
take right away they can insert it check
that's a nice little maneuver I was
thinking you take on e4 straight away
but this is much more forceful yeah and
I mean I've connected passed pawns but
my King is kind of awkward now oh and
look at the follow up idea
this is another important detail they
could pick up the Jeep on I take the
night they take my ruck into moves
alright that's that's an interesting
sequence yeah so now it's just even ish
night age five and rook g4 yeah I was I
don't think I've voiced it in the game
but I didn't want my rook to be cut off
from the defense of the pond so I don't
play rook to g4 that's what couldn't
happen and I'll just drop the pond for
nothing
so rook g4 ensures I keep this defendant
and they put some pressure on the pawn
they're hitting my knight now got to go
over to defend my net has no good
forward moves
he's keeping pressure here but yeah
other than that not too much and now he
requires some support so he goes back b3
and then it's just probably a drawn
position if we we sit I went for
something right around here okay it does
like me this is I guess a winning idea
to take the pawn but I have to be a bit
more mindful of this pawn break so an
instructive moment coming up with a rook
exchange I guess better now I guess in
the end it's just even rook takes it
does like taking with the king and I
guess this is going to be a draw but
yeah who knows how it plays out how it
would play out with the night still on
board 98 and I push and where does it
change that f6 can you f3 hmm
let's see am over-committing here I
think after I drift over towards the
Kings side because this night I wonder
if they had it in their mind in their
mind already to kind of watch out for my
past poems with this kind of idea yeah
because yeah when I have these past
problems on the Queen side he's around
to defend and this is a pun is just so
fast so now it thinks I'm winning at
this point after king g6 h5 check I did
that
and what's the winning attempt to just
push king to h4 oh I guess this is Suk's
Fung King H for my knight isn't far away
he will be in time if black goes for
something like this now the pond doesn't
even reach the second-ranked safely so I
keep my knight on f4 and this move came
to h4 and the King has to concede the g5
square and also maybe I have a knight g4
move and from g4 notice he would only be
two steps away from controlling that
promotion square you know this it need
more time for these kind of end games so
still a lot of calculation going on
unlike bishop and game positions a lot
is based on the understanding you don't
necessarily have to calculate any
specific lines but I guess King h4 yeah
is winning and on a knight move I could
improve my knight with checking I'm
entering King here otherwise I could
pick up this pawn and yeah I'm making
progress here and I'll be able to show
that this is a big positive now that
there isn't this kind of break but yeah
hit at
just the right moment so I played Knight
to h3 and my knight is just a little too
far away and they were spot-on and just
like that it turned so this was the
point where I was winning with King to
h4 and after Knight to h3 I'm losing
because my knight is just one move shy
of being able to stop the eventual past
a pawn d5 nice move and they're breaking
they're giving up some material but they
will be getting a clean and I just can't
stop that yeah and I was lucky to be
able to complicate a little bit they
probably could have just moved the night
here they could still go with what they
did in the game but moving the knight is
probably good too or or is it I guess
I'm yeah okay I guess this is probably
clear something like that but we were we
were belt in bullet mode and I got my
knight into play and I had some kind of
coordination at least going on and a
knight right next to the King like this
it's he's a really good defender against
Queen checks and they in the end didn't
even make a move once it got to this
point right here after b6 maybe they
didn't find a good a good way forward
here because Queen takes pawn so I guess
the one on the last variation is to
check out yeah Queen takes pawn which
might seem really natural isn't winning
it's winning for white because I get to
push and how do you promote how do you
stop promotion here I could still push
through 97 or promote right away clean
takes Queen is met with Knight to d7 I
take here here and white wins but uh
what
Tristan game yeah I think there's a lot
of important things to take away from
this one
okay well I learn something from this
hopefully you did as well feel free as
usual to leave any feedback to this
video in the comment section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you soon that's all for now
take care bye
you